on rit beaucoup de choses de mon papa
d'abord l'éducation l'éducation qui m'a
donné les messages qui m'a transmis et
sa manière de voir le monde et puis de
voir
comment lui il était dans le monde comme
vivait dans le mot comment ils vivaient
une journée une simple journée pour voir
comment il l'abordé comment il l'a il
attaquait la journée quoi
et voila quoi c'est ce qui m'a transmis
en vain une pile à la simplicité aussi
rester simple puis faire ce faire se
faire ce qu'on a à faire tout simplement
voilà quoi c'est faire ce qu'on a à
faire se battre pour faire ses
convictions et puis voilà quoi c'est en
gros c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit j'ai pas pris la dimension la
dimension de sa grandeur franchement je
n'ai pas pris la gelée vu en eau
présentation je l' ai vu quelques
prestations quand j'étais petit mais
c'est vraiment lorsque je suis venu ici
à l'âge de 21 ans que j'ai vraiment pris
conscience de ce qu'il avait fait ce
qu'il avait son parcours son combat
qu'il a mené pour légitimer sa musique
pour prouver que voilà qu'il avait du
poids dans dans le monde musical
d'ici qu'il pouvait qu'on pouvait
compter sur lui
et puis voilà quoi c'est à partir de ce
moment là où j'ai vraiment pris que eh
ben
il a vraiment laissé une trace
indélébile sur la sur la martinique et
puis qu'il a vraiment touché au plus
profond de nous chacun chaque
martiniquais et puis je dirais même dans
la caraïbe et même aussi dans le wap
aussi parce que c'est vrai qu' il n'y a
pas une journée où je n'entends pas
parler de mon papa ou bien qu'on me
donne une anecdote bien qu'on en parle
de lui donc c'est vraiment parce que il
a vraiment laissé une grosse trace
épique à l'aller c'est vraiment ben
voila quoi ses pieds tempez c'est le
pays martinique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi même je suis dans le milieu musical
artistique maintenant c'est vrai que
j'ai mis du temps à me faire à l'idée
que je pouvais faire quelque chose et
puis même accepté l'idée de faire et
d'apprendre
donc les doigts car actuellement 10 dans
musique là est moins mou ça m'enlève
transmettre ces moines y ait moins c'est
voilà quoi c'est malik aux musiques la
comac a joué à 400 points tout
simplement
[Applaudissements]